mekka one of the most sacred cities in
this land public prayers to marquis v
have been taking place but only a few
dozen worshippers gathered at the Great
Mosque Saudi Arabia has imposed
around-the-clock curfew after infections
surged to nearly 70,000 it's a different
picture in Pakistan though where large
gatherings have been spotted across the
country in its biggest city Karachi
public prayers to markeith have taken
place despite the threat of the virus
spreading Muslim scholars are urging
people to follow social distancing
during celebrations unlike many other
countries under lockdown people in Iran
are being allowed to pray inside mosques
president Hassan rouhani has been easing
restrictions since April some businesses
historical sites and museums are being
allowed to reopen from Sunday but the
government is urging people not to
travel during the Eid holiday same
basarat' he has been talking to people
in the capital we're here in downtown
Tehran and on any other Eve before the
corona virus pandemic this would have
been a very different scene one of the
main areas for prayers in the city the
mosula where the supreme leader
Ayatollah Khamenei with lead prayers and
then deliver a sermon Iranian say
millions would gather there to offer
prayer services that was completely
canceled in downtown some mosques were
allowed to hold prayers that were
limited prayer congregations across the
city across the country the mosque
behind me there were plans to have
prayers this morning but they were
cancelled last minute and people were
moved to the mosque on the campus of
Tehran University to facilitate the eath
prayer services there but where there
would have been on the streets outside
the university in the university campus
inside the mosque where there would have
been thousands this day there were only
dozen certainly an impact of kovat 19
really keeping people at home people
still taking social distancing seriously
when it comes to congregations like this
one woman we met said it was the first
time she'd left her home since the
control measures were put in place since
the lockdown quarantine
measures were put in place months ago
another family we met said they were
from the northern was under on province
one of the epicenters for the corona
virus outbreak and they'd been stuck
because they were observing the
intercity travel ban that had been in
place for weeks and months now that
though has been lifted many people are
not observing it and is something that
the Health Ministry has warned people
against during the no ruse the Persian
New Year the travel across the country
is something that helped spread the
virus very quickly to all provinces in
Iran the Health Ministry here before the
Eid day did warn people not to engage in
that kind of travel however at the same
time president Hassan rouhani has said
that tourist sites will begin to reopen
that restaurants and cafes will begin to
reopen later this week certainly the
government is doing the calculus the
math about an acceptable level of an
infection and death rates to start
getting the country moving forward again